since 1997 researchers at the University
of Sussex have monitored global trends
in armed conflict their research clearly
shows that in Africa over the last 10
years armed conflict has gone up by
seven fold let's think about that seven
fold in a single decade why is this we
believe as oxygen is to fire so our
unemployed youth to insecurity we have a
lot of youth on this continent youth
like Sandra who on a Saturday morning in
March 2014 woke up excited at the
prospects of getting a coveted job at
the Nigerian Immigration Services she
kissed her daughter goodbye left her
home never to return
Sandra and 15 other young Nigerians died
that day applying for a job in the
ensuing stampede as tens of thousands of
people applied for a few thousand open
positions
in the last 20 years 20 million youth
have entered the Nigerian workforce
alone today half our population is under
the age of 18 that's almost 18 million
people that will be entering the
workforce in the next 20 years my
friends if a wave of 20 million people
entering the workforce triggered Niger
Delta crisis Fulani herdsman crisis and
Boko Haram I ask you what will four
times that number do to do my part to
solve this challenge in 2012 I moved to
a small village in northern Nigeria in
the centre of the area most recently hit
by the spread of insecurity brutal
bombings and searing poverty with an
idea could we create an economic buffer
to halt the spread of this insecurity by
unlocking the power of agriculture as a
job creation engine we knew this had
been done before in countries like
Thailand where in 1980 they suffered
from the same economic challenges as us
today however Thailand produces 2
million cars a year more than the United
Kingdom with over 30% of its workforce
as highly commercial profitable small
farmers with an unemployment rate of
less than 1% how did they do this in the
80s Thailand dramatically improved the
productivity of its small farmers
ensuring that it was able to start to
dominate export markets for produce
building on this strength the attracted
investment and started to
process being able to export higher
value products like starch from cassava
finely coupled with investment in
education they started to expand to even
higher value manufacturing to make our
idea a reality and follow a path similar
to Thailand we knew that we would have
to sell young farmers on farming a young
man in northern Nigeria for the purpose
of today's discussion will call Sami new
made it very clear to me that this would
not be easy Samina grew up in a
beautiful village in northern Nigeria
and he tells wonder stories of playing
for hours with his friends running up
and down the beautiful rock formations
that built the countryside around his
home
despite this beauty Cimino knew that the
first chance he got he would leave he
did not want to be a farmer growing up
he saw his parents worked so hard as
farmers but barely get by as he says
they had Babu
nothing young farmers like Sami new do
not have access to the cash to buy the
farming products to pair with their hard
work to be successful when their meager
harvest came in desperate for cash they
would sell most of it at fire sale
prices when if they could just wait six
months they could get 50% more hence
Sami knew left to the city where he soon
realized that life was not easy he
borrowed a very old motorcycle with
tires there were more patches than tyres
to become a motorcycle taxi driver he
lived in constant fear every day
that his precious tattered motorcycle
would be ripped away from him as it had
before but he got it back thankfully he
knew of others however who are not so
lucky
other young men who once they lost their
motorcycles became destitute angry these
young men set out to wreak vengeance on
a society that they believed had turned
its back on them tsamina told me that
they join insurgent groups often acting
as getaway drivers in bombings and
kidnappings to end this cycle of
insecurity we must make farming a viable
choice we must ensure that these young
men on their small farms can earn enough
money to make a life for themselves to
make a future the question now is how
recognizing that Africa has grassroot
level leadership we simply developed a
model to bring the professional
management and investment to scale to
these grassroot leaders we called it
ba-bang gona great farm in house' upon
reaching the village in 2012 i traveled
from community to community trying to
convince people of our idea trying to
recruit farmer members we failed
woefully that first year the early
recruiting one hundred brave souls but
we persevered we kept doing what we
promised slowly regain their trust
more farmers join us fast-forward now
five years with a passionate and
committed team and the tremendous
support of our partners we grew
dramatically today serving twenty
thousand small farmers enabling them to
double their yields and triple their net
income relative to their peers we are
very proud of the fact fast forward
three years
Cimino has earned enough money to buy
three goats for his mother to start a
goat rain business owns his own retail
store and bought not one but two
motorcycles with vanity license plates
ba-bang gonna my friends in the next 20
years
over 400 million Cimino's are entering
the african workforce with potentially
half of them having opportunities in
agriculture to unlock these
opportunities through models similar to
ours they would require one hundred and
fifty billion dollars a year in
financing this is a big number but if we
can tap into commercial debt it is a
small number only 0.1% of all the debt
in the world today 10 cents out of every
hundred dollars this is why we designed
our model to be very different from
conventional agricultural development
programs in a few short years we have
shown that our model works is
high-impact and can turn a profit
attracting commercial investors that do
not typically invest in small farmers in
Africa imagine a world where millions of
young men across
for the hard-working young men have
other options I know these driven
ambitious young men will make the right
choice we can realize this dream if they
have a choice thank you
[Applause]